ce sont vos produits préférés fabriqué
par les géants de l'alimentation au
coeur de la guerre des prix dans la
grande distribution
depuis ce matin les grandes surfaces
sont appelés à augmenter leurs marges
pour en laisser un peu plus au
producteur
la facture du consommateur augmente de
7% en moyenne
et on paye plus cher pour les choses de
marque mais ça on l'a toujours fait donc
c'est pas une surprise mais ça augmente
toi c'est plutôt énervant encore ces
voix là c'est le encore qui est énervant
on suit pas prêtes à payer plus cher
n'étant pas vraiment certaine
que la marge va effectivement rapporté
aux producteurs quoi ça s'arrête pas
d'entente est ce que ça soit l'essence
ou ou les courses où tout et puis le
salaire il sut pas quoi alors qu'on a du
mal à joindre les bouts
malheureusement pour cette agricultrice
la loi ne changera pas la donne
le blé est une céréale qui se vend peu
cher et en masse les marges sont trop
infimes pour cueillir % puisse y changer
quelque chose
deuxième argument des cultivateurs les
produits concernés sont des aliments
transformés à base de matières premières
très souvent importés le capitaux ne
sera pas fait avec le champ d'à côté
ni forcément le pain de mie harris à
châteauroux alors il ya un marché
mondial un cours donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faudrait que en fait l'europe on
protège autres critiques avancées par
les producteurs la loi n'est pas
contraignante
son succès dépend de la bonne volonté
des distributeurs et de l'autre famille
d'hyères la capacité de redistribuer
aller à l'industriel lé pas aux
distributeurs
le seul gallic laissé l'industriel et on
n'a pas vraiment confiance dans
l'industriel puisque son but c'est pas
de faire gagner de l'argent à ses
fournisseurs se ferment le dispositif
est en vigueur pour deux ans au moins le
gouvernement n'excluent pas
l'instauration d'un contrôle des prix
une réunion est fixée avec les syndicats
la semaine prochaine